[Music]
good morning John it's Tuesday November
6th holy crap holy crap holy crap if I
can and I haven't bye baby yo I just
want to be famous
anybody who's a significantly harder on
the road especially when you're staying
a lot to friends houses because they're
expecting you to be in the kitchen
hanging out do you have to do a video
and I can hear you talking in here and
they're like who the is he talking
to but then they realize and I'm talking
to you John
talk to you it's all so hard your video
camera down Cynthia no we spend all day
seeing awesome things that you cannot
Ben you tape because you left it in your
friend's house and you locked yourself
out and so you couldn't make your video
until I kind of like a night so this is
why this video is going to be asked John
thanks for the update about Pakistan
unfortunately I have no idea what you're
talking about I'm really sorry about
that but I don't it's confusing so if
you can give me a little bit more
information about what's going on in
Pakistan and who this bad guy is and why
he's so bad I think that both I and the
nerdfighters would appreciate that and
we would also appreciate it if you would
do it while consuming some kind of
inedible item for example these gourmet
pretzels that you get on all Air Tran
flights in fact it's all you get if your
flight a 17 hours long they will offer
you more packages of bar made pretzels
instead of something of any substance
they will give you more of these they're
happy to share with you these little
packets of desiccated doom on a more
domestic front I think the George Bush
also will deep into the soul of Dick
Cheney and saw a really good person but
I think just one of the reasons that I
support the impeachment of Dick Cheney I
do they're also about 328 other reasons
why I support the impeachment of Dick
Cheney but that's one of them
so because we can't really impeach
George Bush before we impeach Dick
Cheney because I think that would be
about trade we got to do dick first and
then Bush and then I don't I don't know
who comes after that
that's something else that I'd like you
to clear up for me who comes next if you
kick both the president and the vice
president out of office I just looked it
up its Speaker Nancy Pelosi that's
totally worth it
you can get voted him out I have nice
boys you take off for everybody
it doesn't taste very good I like worse
than the pretzels okay John I'm getting
this a little bit Church so I got to go
I will see you tomorrow
title teases polish rareness phallic
lotion floundered hustler infallibly
loud search hard it might be a tight fit
under there